hey guys it is Friday which means I've
got the five best stories of the whole
gaming week all ready to go for you
here's what matters we're never really
quite sure what's going on between
Konami and had a Kojima and this week
has been no exception earlier this week
an article in The New Yorker suggested
that today Okajima had left Konami and
Kojima Productions noting that a
departure ceremony was thrown for the
veteran game designer on october nine
Konami later refuted these planes and
insisted that kojima is simply on
vacation after the conclusion of metal
gear solid 5 s development Simon parking
the journalist who wrote the article for
The New Yorker subsequently tweeted out
a photo of the leaving party as evidence
of the ceremony which Konami supposedly
claims to have no knowledge of the
article also noted that Kojima has a
non-compete clause which expires in
December but those that are currently
having a massive fallout themed sale and
they've announced a very cool vault boy
themed Xbox one controller to coincide
with the sale Bethesda announced a new
line of fallout branded much including a
very bright but very cool vault boy
themed Xbox one controller some of the
items do have limited availability
though such as the limited edition
fallout 4 art book and a vault Tec thing
watch
this week in exceptional deals you'll
soon have the chance to pick up an xbox
one Gears of War ultimate edition bundle
plus a copy of fallout 4 and an extra
controller for 300 bucks that crazy
sweet deal comes from Dell as one of
their black friday specials according to
an ad scan posted to BF ads the deal
launches on November 26 through dell's
website starting at 6pm EDT so if you
had your eye on an xbox one anyway
you'll probably want to get on that
quick the latest GTA online update
entitled lowriders is now available and
unsurprisingly it puts a bunch of low
riders in the game the update introduces
a car customization gosh called Benny's
original motor works where you can deck
out your car with hydraulics new wheels
and rims custom gear shift levers horn
and plenty more crap you don't need but
probably want there are two new vehicles
the de classe moonbeam then and the
Willard function as well as new contact
missions and new guns and three new
adversary modes for the full list of
changes and additions check out a story
on gamespot
finally the price for the star wars
battlefront Ultimate Edition has been
announced and it's pretty expensive the
premium version of the game is set to
cost 120 bucks on pc ps4 and xbox one
which is twice the price of the base
game The Ultimate Edition includes the
base game the fifty-dollar DLC pass and
deluxe edition content which includes
the ion grenade I on torpedo Han Solo's
dl 44 blaster eye on Chaka moat and the
victory emotes the deluxe edition cells
with 70 bucks on its own and EA access
members will be able to get ten percent
of the price of any of the content packs
including the base game let me know down
in that comment section what you cared
about this week and what you think of
the star wars battlefront prices this
week on psyched I go over the best Super
Mario maker levels on the gist Lucy
talks Assassin's Creed syndicate on in
two minutes and we build a fallout 4
volt boy statue thanks for joining us as
always the US will be taking care of
your news needs next week so I will see
you after that be sure to have a great
weekend